good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast and happy Thursday
hope everyone's having a great Thursday
welcome back to the morning shows hey
Jax how you doing I'm doing great
because it's the first Thursday of June
which means that the new redheads
episode is out so go check it out if you
read the book and even if you didn't
it's actually so fun funny and cute and
I was editing the episode last night and
at the end before I go up to like end
the recording you can hear all of our
chatter and I actually almost left it in
because it was so cute like everyone was
like that was such a good one Tina's
like that was so fun you should have
left it in I know it just felt like so
private yeah it really was such a good
one and so fun and you should definitely
check it out and it's never too late to
become a redhead but redheads aside we
have so much to do today I'm sure that
people are watching this episode and
being like wow four legs bear two queens
wearing outfits that they never wear
they treat this set like trash why do
they look like goddesses today yeah we
treat it like our living room which is
what it is we look like goddesses
because Spirits is having such an
exciting day new flavor launches today
right now right now right now right now
if you don't already know the new flavor
is peach I have been able to drink it
for the last month when I tell you how
much it tastes literally like Snapple
like it's so good it's so refreshing of
course we have a code we'll get to all
that but this is our first new flavor
after our capsule collection you guys
know we have four flavors grapefruit
lemon blood orange and pineapple this is
our first additional flavor and it's
so good some ASMR from Jackie from ASMR
it's so good Zach poured me one on ice
last night and it was delicious and it's
safe to say this is my favorite flavor
now it has usurped grapefruit even
though the originals are so good we love
them but it's the usurper I'm sorry
she's coming in hot no this can is
literally Aries Targaryen she's coming
in half she's a usurper
oh she is you guys it's so so good so if
you want to order it online it will be
in the stores that we're in it'll be in
soon but right now you can get it
exclusively online Sports Society has
officially launched our new flavor Peach
and we've been dying to share it with
you all Peach will be joining Spirit
society's four iconic flavors just in
time for summer it's juicy it's vibrant
and it's bursting with flavor Peach is
the official flavor of the season so you
can shop the peach at spritzociety.com
and since you're a toaster and you
deserve the world and you mean the world
to me we have a code for you it's Life's
a peach that's 15 off 65 or more Life's
a peach for 15 off Sports society.com
get the variety pack try the new flavor
if you haven't tried it yet this might
be this your time might be coming it
might be now nothing goes together
better than the toast and the Spritz you
know
and a chicken nugget oh a french fry for
me right because if we're drinking we
have to have something to eat you know
of course you don't want to get too
carried away you want to be
irresponsible no no no no so it's a big
day Alfresco let me set the scene please
please poolside or on rooftop if you're
in a city and I'm sorry if you are
poolside Beachside toast
on the speakers in your airpods Spritz
in a glass over ice with a straw plastic
I would go for peach french fries
ketchup videos Bryce Theo strice Bryson
Streisand that does sound like an
idyllic day we should make it happen for
ourselves we should cultivate that Vibe
we are in charge of our own destiny yet
we do nothing about it not a thing not a
thing all we do is sit here and complain
we could have that Vibe cooked up in a
second
we should work on that we are working on
that but until then head over to sports
society.com and the reason why we look
so nice is because we're throwing a big
you know media influencer brunch to
celebrate the new peach so we've got to
do the toast we've got to head downtown
to you know prepare for the girlies so
girls are arriving and we cannot
disappoint no and some of us have to
pump in between so pray for us pray for
us in perpetuity oh and as if that's not
enough there is news Galore today
one of those shows that we can fumble
through so true there's so much to talk
about the Johnny heard the Johnny heard
trial the Jubilee was this morning I was
watching it this morning me too premium
content it's a lot there's so much to
talk about and I think we need to just
talk about it because we could talk
about ourselves the only thing that's
really going on for me today is the new
episode of the redheads check it out
that's all I'm gonna say and also at
this point it's kind of like canva Pro
it's like passion no what are you doing
if you're not using it so true not on
canva Pro when you're not listening to
the redheads like you can't help you and
it's like when we get on this podcast
and try and like convince people to get
the redheads it's like we're insulting
their intelligence because it's so
obvious you know it's disgusting of us
get your [ __ ] ass up and listen to
the redheads check it out and before
that here are the past five stories that
you need to know before you wake up and
take a bite out of your morning toast
today's episode is of course brought to
you by spritzociety.com our new flavor
just launched Life's a peach for that 15
off code over uh 65 or more check it out
spritzociety.com gorgeous our first
story is the big story of the day Johnny
Depp won his defamation case against
Amber Heard he has been awarded 15
million dollars in Damages combined
Amber was awarded on one count she was
awarded two million dollars so net 13
mil but there is a pain there is a law
in Virginia that puts a cap on punitive
damages where he was awarded 5 million
so the max she could get for that is uh
350 50 000 so all in all ten point three
five minus the two million right so we
were together watching the the verdict
and when I tell you like how I gasped
because whether or not like whatever
side you're on it's incredibly difficult
to prove defamation like it's it's like
the hardest thing so whether or not you
believe Johnny or you believe Amber like
the legal feat of this was huge and I
was genuinely like Beyond shocked yeah I
was also shocked that he was awarded so
much money I think a lot of people
thought that he might win but
for a dollar for a dollar just to make
the point that you can't run around
saying things that aren't true about
people but you know he's not going to
get the 50 million dollars right he had
wanted and I think he had stated
previously like this really wasn't about
money I don't think that it was either
but so to be awarded like so much money
and really win on all counts she won the
one count so he was okay he was suing
her for multiple accounts about an op-ed
she wrote In The Washington Post which I
want to get into in a second
multiple accounts for multiple things
she said in this one op edit on every
single account that he had sued her for
he won
she then counter-sued he basically had a
lawyer release a statement to the Daily
Mail so she used that as her accounter
claim for defamation the Waldman
statements and there were multiple
accounts and only one of them the jury
found to be true and they awarded her
two million dollars so she did have a
very very small win obviously no one's
talking about that because he had a
magnanimous win and the crazy part like
just from a you know celebrity
entertainment perspective is that he was
not even there and he was there every
single day of the trial he took the
stand multiple times and so on the final
day where he was reaching a verdict I
don't know if maybe because he thought
he lost I don't know what the reasoning
was but he was not there
it's very Kardashians China yeah trial
maybe because whether he won or lost
it's hard you don't want to have your
reaction shown and now he's gonna go
live his life his work here is done
regardless of what the outcome was he
did everything that he could with the
trial and it's kind of iconic that he
wasn't there yeah and we're just like
left to be watching her yeah and those
are all the pictures that are coming out
obviously her face dropped when it was
just yes yes yes yes yes five million 10
million no no like so and the camera
just stayed on her the entire time yeah
there was nowhere else for it to go
perhaps that was what Johnny wanted I
don't know
um it was just a crazy thing to watch it
felt historic in a way I felt like you
know something like a trial where people
get so invested like we'll be talking
about for years to come yeah and it's
something that everyone's watching and
obviously like the law and crime Channel
on YouTube having a great day yesterday
I'm actually today thinking of the hosts
of The Long crime challenge they were
quaking they had so many technical
difficulties have that many you know
that much three million people watching
only on their channel right which is
insane I mean maybe if there's another
trial like this that captures the
attention of the world but you know
today's a quiet day for them yeah and
immediately upon the verdict being
reached both Johnny and Amber had
statements released on their Instagram
the sentiment of Johnny's was like I
feel free I feel like I've Vindicated
myself for my myself and my children and
my family
um I feel like I can finally start a new
chapter in my life and ambers was very
much um you know uh this verdict
reinforces The Stereotype that victims
of abuse women shouldn't speak up
um so they were both pretty much like
sticking to their stories given I mean I
would hope so it's not like she's gonna
now say oh never mind I didn't fool you
but I mean given that a jury has weighed
in on all the way we always say
innocence we're guilty but like the jury
has weighed in all of the evidence was
submitted everyone made their case and
seven juries of their peers decided yeah
that she's a [ __ ] liar yeah given
that she's the one doing more damage to
victims of domestic abuse and violence
than this verdict yeah considering she's
the one who lied and up until this point
like you know we were believing women
right and now she's like making it so
that we're questioning yeah I don't know
it's um it's very delicate in the sense
that like what now that we have this
verdict
what do we do with it like because I
think for so long we've all been
conditioned and we should believe women
but like there's what about if they're
lying right but there's like now legal
proof that it just hits like such a bad
it said such a bad example such a bad
example she's the one doing it so she
can't say that like you know she's
worried about women when you're the one
the messed it up no end there was
mountains of evidence that she was
abusive right so I think what we take
away from this trial is one like men can
be victims of abuse two like we should
be very
um we should all be like cautious of
what we read and three like where is the
uh
accountability on behalf of the
Washington Post and the ACLU so a lot of
people were confused as to why the trial
was happening in Virginia and the reason
that is is because what Johnny was doing
her over was an op-ed that she wrote In
The Washington Post and the Washington
Post is located in Virginia so this
whole trial was about the Washington
Post and I just feel like isn't there
some sort of accountability on the
Washington Post to
be publishing the truthfulness right to
investigate what they're publishing so I
think it also poses like a really big
question about like media and journalism
you know it's just kind of like this
crazy
trial that is like making people
question a lot of things yeah as it
should it really should because if he
hadn't gone for it and decided that he
was going to clear his name we would
have just stayed put him in the category
Amber he would have been canceled I mean
now let's let's see pirate six right
this man has been totally like
Vindicated Vindicated and but for six
years like his life was completely
upended based on what the jury has
decided was a lie yeah
no which was not only just told by her
but then propagated by like one of the
biggest newspapers in the country and
then everyone would buy like a civil
liberties Union that's supposed to be
defending victims right no it's a bad
look for a lot of people yeah no I I
wouldn't be surprised if a lot of people
are questioning a lot of things yeah as
they should as they should question
everything by the way question what it
says on the board above you know in the
classroom totally there's no such thing
as a dumb question never stop asking why
so it was just like it was crazy and
it's also crazy how Johnny's legal team
has become like a level of celebrity you
know people were quaking obviously they
weren't going to wait for Johnny to come
out because he wasn't there but
literally waiting for like Ben Chu and
Camille Vasquez to give a statement like
cheering for them and Camille Vasquez is
an associate and she like really became
the star of the trial and like in her I
do believe like she has a very bright
legal career ahead of her or very bright
you know publishing career when she
wants to write a book about this well
that's what we were talking about the
jury obviously if you've been watching
the trial every day you never see the
jury you don't know I know they were
comprised of five women five men and two
women was that what I heard on Law and
Order right Law and Order so it was so
seven people
um which I found shocking because I just
assumed Jerry's 12 Angry Men you know
but I guess because it's a civil course
case not a criminal case it's seven
um you learned something new every day
but we never got to see who that was
like who were the people what did they
look like and so now it's kind of like
how OJ after the trial every single
person wrote a book I don't think this
trial is at the level that OJ was but I
do think like we'll be getting some
sit-down interviews a GMA moment
something with some of the jurors if
they're into it if they're into it which
they probably are they sat through all
of this it's hard to be a juror we were
talking about that too because they
finally panned to the jury seats once
the jury exited the courtroom and I was
like oh my God these people have been
sitting in these turnt Twisted hard ass
chairs for 12 hours a day for six weeks
straight like I could never be a juror
like my back is in such bad shape I
would need a heating pad on the stand
and I feel like that wouldn't they
wouldn't let me the only thing is is
like you also were listening to the same
thing that they were listening to for 12
hours a day for six weeks treat yes you
were in your bed but if you had just
done in that chair like you would be set
for life with another book no okay with
no job the sequel first of all I only
started watching crazy beautiful life of
a juror I only started watching two
weeks ago and I only watched like three
hours a day so like having the option to
turn it off when it got boring which it
very frequently did with like legal
stuff
um I don't think I could really and they
were always like being excused get up
get down like it was a lot it is a lot
yeah
got to figure out how to get out of jury
duty I I don't know you could end up on
a case like this well of course like if
I get to jury duty and they're doing a
celebrity trial like duh I'll think
about it but if it's you know termites
against the landlord like I'm not I'm
not doing it okay I feel like you would
like it you would get so much material
you would come in every day okay we're
jealous with your Tails that's true also
like you would have such interesting
juror Dynamics like when you guys break
for lunch like whatever I would start a
click are you gonna start a click I
would be sitting alone in the corner
because I don't know how to talk to
people
um hopefully someone would you know
bring me in take me under their way we
would need to do jury duty together
literally and then I would open up to
the group and they would say oh my God
she has such personality like we thought
you were so shy and I'm like yeah that's
what everyone says because I'm really
shy yeah I'm sure but I also do have a
big personality but only once you get to
know me and I feel comfortable
um so this just concludes like closes a
chapter on something that I feel like
we've all been so invested in we all I
think a lot of people like I think most
most people are team Johnny and
especially if you've been watching the
trial it was hard not to be yeah and now
with the verdict being what it is
even if you weren't paying attention the
whole time like they went through
everything they combed through their
text messages it was so embarrassing for
everyone like and he decided to open up
his life like that in pursuit of
clearing his name and there was
unflattering things about him yeah but
overall I mean the drug use the alcohol
some of his text messages like things he
would just say to his friends like where
everyone does things in their personal
life that are Beyond embarrassing and
now it makes me think like I've got to
clean up my act in case I ever get sued
for defamation right yeah
because your entire life becomes public
yeah and before this trial like you
could not catch me caring about Johnny
Depp in one way or another yeah didn't
see his movies actually we were talking
about some of his movies yesterday right
because I don't think I actively like
sought out to see Johnny Depp movies but
obviously I've seen a lot like What's
Eating Gilbert Grape Alice in Wonderland
Charlie and the Chocolate Factory Peter
Pan he does yeah a lot of Disney I
didn't even realize that and then of
course the Pirates movies which I've
never seen I've never seen them but the
uh like a few weeks ago Zach was
watching one so I caught a bit of the
end it was pretty good it's it's like
historical fiction I'm just curious to
see like where these two go from here
like I don't think it'll be easy for
Amber to get work
um because there's so much
Scandal attached to her name in a
negative way like her Q score they did a
whole thing in the trial about Q scores
I don't think she has a high one and
Johnny
um I know he hasn't done movies in a
while and and through the trial you
realize because opportunities were taken
away from him because people believed
him to be you know an abuser but I don't
know if he even wants to keep doing
movies I know he's like in a band or
something he likes playing music and
that's why he wasn't even at the trial
right he was in the UK playing a show
with his band yeah exactly
oh he was in 21 Jump Street the TV
series he forgot that that was a reason
it's so Random so Random they were
talking about 21 Jump Street actually in
the trial and I was like what that's
really funny it was so interesting to
hear like these cultural yeah things
like Aquaman Pirates of the Caribbean
the show Amber did where she got paid
like 200 000 an episode it was just so
crazy to see all that played out in a
court of law you're just not used to
that no you're really not so that's that
on that trial and it will be interesting
to see what see what they each do next I
can imagine a lot of people don't want
to work with her because
it seems like she invites drama yeah
trouble Trump lies yeah so also the fact
this was not publicly favorable towards
her because even if Johnny had lost
still the that's what we were saying
yeah but so the court of public opinion
the court of public opinion like had
really changed in how they felt about
him yeah she lost
and and then some and then some exactly
yeah because I I think for both of them
of course Johnny wanted to win but I
think the way that the people watching
millions of people watching every day
started to see him in a different light
was really his goal and so just to
actually win the the verdict was a
cherry on top of that because I was 100
certain he was not gonna win it's so
hard trust me I've tried to sue people
for defamation like I want to do it
every time someone says something mean
about me it's really hard yeah also I
was on Daily Mail this morning they had
a headline like it was really a trial by
Tick Tock they said it was uh hashtag
Justice for Johnny or something like
that has 81 billion views wow so people
were really getting their
their information but also I want to say
like their opinions yeah their facts and
their opinions I went through like a
journey on this trial because at first I
was like oh good for Amber like let's go
and then I started getting targeted with
like Johnny content I was like wait are
we seeing this all wrong
and then I got so much Johnny content I
had to like pull my head out of my ass
and be like I think I might be like
being
biased biased like I think I might be
like getting um what's the word I'm
looking for
propaganda so then I just started
watching the trial and like forming my
own opinions and then like seeking out
other sources of information and I came
to the conclusion that like I'm pretty
sure
um
we're Team job I'm team Johnny yeah and
then the jury agreed with but I'm like
afraid to say that you know what I mean
I know but now that's because it sounds
it sounds bad right because you want to
believe women yeah this woman says that
she's a victim of domestic violence and
like your heart goes out when you hear
something like that because that's a
natural human instinct but she
allegedly and clearly has really prayed
on that instinct from a lot of people
and put this out about him knowing that
it would damage him and in turn damage a
lot of victims and survivors of domestic
violence because people might feel
differently about saying something
because now maybe we're not just going
to blanket believe women yeah no I it's
just it's definitely a pivotal moment in
like the metoo movement yeah
so it's wild it was a crazy six weeks
crazy also I saw a funny thing that was
like it was the defecation trial
obviously waiting for defecation I mean
that's kind of I think what got people
invested in the trial like the claim
that's a human being would take a [ __ ]
and another human being's bed was so
abhorrent so for me that was at least my
first entry into knowing about what was
going on between these two me too and
like everything else that was
embarrassing that came out you know
drugs alcohol even crude text messages
[ __ ] the bed is out there beyond the
pail it's up there yeah
are you ready for our next story some
exciting news this morning as the
Queen's Jubilee has kicked off the
four-day celebration celebrating her 70
years on the throne the Queen's birthday
uh parade at the house guards in London
was the first official Jubilee event
this morning the royal family took to
the balcony to watch the planes the
immediate family stood there then a more
extended family and of course the big
question is Harry and Megan they were
not on the balcony they were not on the
balcony but they were there there's like
one photo of Megan
um like playing with some kids in the
background
um so there's a lot to unpack here first
of all it's so nice to see the family
out together I really haven't seen the
kids the grandkids in so long
um they I know this is like how genetics
works but they really look like both
their parents like it's crazy like
they're literally the perfect
combination of both like you can see so
much of William and they the two boys
like have Williams hair from
from when he was a kid do you think and
I'm hoping choice or that's how I think
it's genetic and I'm hoping that Kate's
wonderful locks will bring them through
the rest of their life with thick hair
okay that's what I'm thinking so it was
so great to see the queen out and about
looking happy and healthy knock wood
um and just seeing the gang back
together and then of course like the
looming kind of cloud over this is like
what is going on with Harry and Megan
and so they were in attendance I know I
was watching
um
the Jubilee where the newscaster said so
they're all going for lunch now
afterwards like there is going to be
like a bit of a probably awkward family
lunch because William and Charles they
haven't seen Harry yeah the Royals
they're just like us no it's like it's
literally like an awkward family reunion
yeah that is wild I mean it's really
nice to see them all in the balcony we
haven't had a moment like this in a few
years and I really feel like it
signifies like the end of like covid and
what the last two years have been like
if you look at the crowds there's crowds
as far as the eye can see and it's
giving you know Royal Fanfare like it
always has uh
the Harry and Megan thing is so
interesting and I actually was just
reading an article and I saw a picture
and I hadn't ever thought about like
what it's I think about like Megan Moore
because she's far more interesting but
like for Harry to go back to the UK and
like I saw this picture of him where
he's like doesn't know how to smile
because it's like you abandon these
people like this country like raised you
this country rights you and you kind of
took a big [ __ ] on them and left and you
don't even live here anymore it's
different you're talking about the
people of the UK not his family the
people of the UK and how he must feel
like driving down the street like being
like yeah because not only did he step
down for Memorial duties which may be
like if it was a toxic situation for
them and it wasn't working out I can
understand but like they also left the
country like he's choosing not to live
there he's choosing to live in Hollywood
and like he just like left these people
and like the country really like loves
him and William and like when Diana
passed away like they didn't care like
their children and he kind of is just
like
gave them the middle finger yes but also
like how can you make decisions for your
life for people you actually don't
[ __ ] know like of course but it you
and I couldn't most people couldn't but
I imagine that's what the member of the
royal family like that's all you're
doing your whole damn life yeah and now
you're 30. how old is he I don't know
maybe like 40 years old and you have to
think differently you thought about them
for 40 years yeah no like I totally get
it it's there's definitely like an
extremely awkward like Vibe everywhere
Harry and Megan go in the UK
um but you know what
I'm glad they showed up for Queenie
Queenie is like the one person I mean
they named their daughter after her like
queenies I think the one person who they
still you know stomach and have respect
for so I guess that's good yeah
I don't know it's just it's so like you
think your family interactions are
awkward like this pales your parents are
pails in comparison I can't even really
but they're there of course it feels
like it's like of course they're going
to be there it's the queen and they love
her and
but remember the interview
yeah
like they
to me that's like final because I
understand There's issues like in the
family but you you share it in private
yes to air it means like we're done with
them and that's all all good and fine
but you're going back to the Jubilee now
and if you want to make a reproix and
you like that was your way of putting
everything out there so that we can come
back from it then everything like that
needs to be done in the public yeah but
that's not the Royal way no you don't
just air the dirty laundry in public and
then reconcile in private because what
about us we're just left thinking like
what yeah you know so even if they were
to like apologize to the family like
they also need to apologize publicly but
I don't even think they're sorry I think
they feel good about it no I think they
feel like they did what they had to do
they feel Justified I think for them it
was like this supposed to be this clean
break but you can't clean break from
family no also if it's a clean break
then like you don't go back for the gym
right
no I don't really know it's so bizarre
the
because you're right like to do an
interview and say everything you've
wanted to say means like you're done
with these people right which are
welcome to be done and you're totally
justified in doing like everyone is out
here just protecting themselves so then
to like put on a fake face for everyone
and go to the Jubilee that's confusing
yeah so I was confused no it's
definitely Beyond confusing yeah but I
think it's confusing for them too like I
don't think they know where they stand I
don't think the royal family knows like
who and Harry and Megan hate who they
like yeah also Harry and Megan are
filming a reality show for Netflix
I hear a lot about like projects Harry
and Megan are doing that never come to
fruition and like of course the
archetype podcast uh never heard that it
came out Disney plus never heard that it
came out Netflix never heard I know she
wrote a children's book and that book I
did see actually get published so I
don't know I can't keep up with like
their never-ending list they're
literally us like Moguls no for sure no
but we create content on a daily basis
no like they created one episode for
Spotify in the 20 million deal over the
course of two years yeah and like maybe
the stuff they do does come out but it's
clearly not very popular no it like did
nothing has come out I know and like the
the concept of reality show is kind of
crazy it's like that's a fall from grace
100 I think they're calling it like
unscripted documentary style Kardashians
yeah
but I think that's happening and they I
think they're already filming it and the
cameras were like not allowed to be
around this what are they in London with
it I think they might be in London but I
had seen an article that like they're
not these cameras are not allowed
anywhere near no of course but like that
means on the show they're talking about
like going to the Jubilee maybe seeing
William that's crazy and that's very
unroyal like Beyond but I get they're
not active working members of the royal
family so that makes sense but like the
Royal Way has really never been to air
your dirty laundry and the just the sole
fact that they did that interview was so
big but now they're going to let
everyone into their lives episodically
like that's crazy crazy but I really
would love to see more of their
personalities same and their house and
like what their day-to-day is like
because they have a lot of money yeah
but and that Fascination will get people
to tune in for sure but to keep people
interested and on a reality show it's
hard it's really hard yeah I don't know
if the two of them are like boasting
with personality if either one of them
is is probably Megan yeah but I don't
know I think she has that you know way
about her that she's very yes that's
what people said like when she met Harry
she's like this charming princess
I would love to just ask them like one
question like you know you did this huge
thing you left you did the interview
like you left everything you'd ever
known behind Harry Megan you met this
new man and you like whether your
intention was to or not like it was this
big PR thing and like now you're settled
in America like I just want to ask I'm
like is it everything you thought it
would be like because I they're very
low-key and to me like I consider like
low-key to be also like a little
irrelevant and they're not irrelevant
but I wonder if they like the reaction
from America like it was everything they
anticipated I don't know I don't know
America does love them yeah I think that
was really good but I did expect that
they would be at the Met Gala in Cannes
right doing these things that they
couldn't do before so is that a choice
there there definitely could go to the
mechal if they wanted to right so
they're choosing not to do that maybe
they're choosing to do a reality show
like I don't they confuse me like really
Beyond confused yeah and then of course
they go back for this anyways the next
few days will be a lot of fanfare a lot
of Queen nephil celebrations and I
couldn't think of a more worthy Queen I
just really couldn't she's literally a
queen literally okay you ready for our
next story oh [ __ ] um her cards she got
her dropped she dropped her card today's
episode the rest of the stories is
brought to you by Peloton Peloton is
thousands of Live And on-demand classes
so you can always keep it fresh from
cycling and strength training to yoga
and running experiment with new types of
movement in a judgment free zone at a
level and Pace that feels good for you
you're more likely to stick to a workout
routine that you enjoy so Peloton makes
every class fun so it feels like you're
hanging out with friends and nothing
gets you moving like the perfect song
and every Peloton class is set to a bomb
playlist so if you're in the mood to
ride ride a do a full ride of Club
bangers an AGM run a yoga flow class
with soul music whatever you're into
you'll find the perfect soundtrack for
your workout on Peloton and it fits
seamlessly into your life so maybe we're
looking for a 10 minute upper body
stretch or 40 minute run before bed
whatever it is Peloton will work with
your schedule whether you have five
minutes or an hour now I know Jackie
you're a pelotoni queen love palton
obviously I love my Peloton bike changed
my life and now I also love doing other
workouts on the Peloton app including
their tread workouts if you're doing any
sort of run you can do a guided run with
Peloton and you'll work way harder than
if you try to ad-lib your own stuff I
also like to do their body weight
classes a little lightweight arms boot
camp on and off the bike they really
have everything they have yoga if you
want high strength high intensity
workout or low intensity peloton's there
for you couldn't recommend it more if
you want to find follow me in my
workouts I think I'm really good at
curating sick workouts my username is
Jackie ow right now is the perfect time
to try out Peloton a Peloton Bike plus
is now 500 less it's the best price yet
including free delivery and setup and
there are more game changing prices
available on the original Peloton bike
and Peloton tread visit onepeloton.com
to learn more great our next story
exciting skincare news Kim Kardashian
finally is launching her skincare line
skin by Kim
s-k-a-n five years ago she lost she
launched kkw Beauty and now it has
rebranded to skin by Kim she said I'm
excited to finally introduce you to skin
by Kim a rejuvenating nine product
skincare ritual that I have developed
from start to privilege
start to finish I've been so privileged
to learn about skin and Skin Care over
the years from the top world's top
dermatologists and estheticians and
every bottle for my new line is filled
with the knowledge I've accumulated
along the way you know what it's giving
it's giving JLo Beauty like JLo
literally said the same thing like I
have
worked with like the most amazing
dermatologists like I can do this and it
was flop Central and what was the price
point of JLo Beauty pretty high okay
because that's what skin is and I feel
two ways about this as I do most things
because on the one hand like really Kim
Kardashian is not aging she's 41 years
old did you see I mean you did see last
week on the Kardashians when she was
doing the Vogue try ons and she's not
wearing any makeup and she looks like a
kid she looks 28 7. she looked amazing
she's 31 without makeup she looks even
younger than with makeup and so
obviously like whatever she's doing
needs to be bottled and sold for the
rest of us I'm just not convinced that
this is exactly what she's using and I'm
also not convinced what she's doing is
exclusively skin care like everyone gets
Botox like right no no but like I'm sure
maybe these products are probably good
and it seems like they're expensive
she's using high quality ingredients and
sourcing and that's what she said that's
why the price point is high so it's
better than her trying to come in with
like an affordable skincare line and
being like this well that would be like
Kylie's skin right but Kylie has young
skin and we said so the thing is is like
where I disagree with you is like Kim is
aging amazingly in an unnatural way like
the way Kim is aging is obviously due to
I'm sure she takes care of her skin she
stays out of the Sun but it's also the
immense you know resources she has in
plastic surgery and dermatology and all
that stuff she's not aging so like for
me it's like if I really wanted to buy
skincare from someone who was like aging
really well like I would buy like goop
skincare like Gwyneth Paltrow looks
amazing for her age you know she doesn't
look 25 she looks like a grown woman who
looks incredible you know so like
yeah like I'll probably buy it and I
love Kim and this is no slight against
her but like first of all I don't really
feel like she needs another business
venture like first of all people are
literally quaking on Tick Tock like
bring kkw Beauty back her lip liners are
like some of the most popular lip liners
so it's like where is it she went to
relaunch and never came back schemes is
so unbelievably popular and I just feel
like she got to a place like years ago
where she was doing all these random
business ventures like kimoji and it
didn't make sense for her brand and then
she got to an amazing place a few years
ago with the fragrances Beauty and skims
and it's like can't that be enough yeah
because and you actually said something
really smart like yesterday you were
like I would have loved if she had done
this in partnership with Dr Simon Orion
like one of the amazing plastic surgeons
so you would feel like a little bit more
believable believable I don't know and I
think The Branding is great I love the
name
I'll definitely try it but like I don't
know it's giving JLo Beauty it's just
like it's another skin it's another
celebrity makeup skincare line that I
don't feel like is gonna you know change
the industry right whereas she already
has cornered many markets many and I
guess she wants to Corner another and I
do think as far as what approach she
could have taken this is the best one
but
I don't know I was just thinking
yesterday about how like when I saw this
I was like it's just one after the other
we know Road skincare is coming out from
Haley Bieber that I think is like super
on brand she has young fresh amazing
skin I I will be first in line to buy
Road skincare like Dead series wow um
but it's just making me think how like
you know a lot of these cosmetic
companies because like it's this big
bubble and it's like starting to burst
you know Becca Cosmetics is like
completely discontinued for life there's
just like a lot of new brands coming out
that are backed by celebrities and how
like the skin care and beauty industry
is like really becoming like a celebrity
brand
um Market but like if you if you're not
good enough like just because you're a
celebrity doesn't mean you won't flop
like I don't know I feel like a lot of
these celebrity Ventures flap like even
Lady Gaga's makeup is free branded it's
rebranding from Amazon to
um it was backed by Amazon and now it's
backed by I was just watching a tick
tock Sephora yes they went to Sephora
which so I think in the celebrity makeup
category Fenty Beauty and rare Beauty
are the top two and Kylie cosmetics and
Kylie Cosmetics
um and then there's also an interesting
category where like celebrity makeup
artist Brands become it like that's Pat
McGrath that's Charlotte Tilbury that's
makeup by Mario which is really popular
but then there's like this this like
cash grab yeah so and I think that's
like REM Beauty from Ariana Grande it's
house Laboratories it's halsey's line
it's Kesha's line it's like it's kind of
even though some of her products I've
heard are really good Alicia Keys
skincare like I haven't heard a lot
about it Jayla Beauty flop Central like
it's just like I didn't even know some
of these people had makeup I know and
it's like it's too late no and it is a
cash crab and at a certain point
especially with skin care I want the
real I want the scientists yeah you know
because the celebrities or the talent
like they have their day jobs like
they're not in the lab thinking about
how to neutralize my redness she should
have really done a partnership with
Simon Orion like she's giving him a
million dollars or like a small stake in
the company just so people could believe
that like this is what her and her
dermatologist and plastic surgeon all
use yeah I just don't think we need this
honestly yeah I and since it is
expensive it's not something I'll just
like try to let you guys know you know
yeah and it is nine step and if I'm
gonna try it I'm going for all nine no
and if I'm buying if I'm spending a
thousand dollars on skincare like your
ass you bet your ass I'm buying lemare
you bet bet your ass so I don't know so
here's what the nine things are a
cleanser toner exfoliator hyaluronic
acid serum vitamin C serum face cream
eye cream oil drops and night oil and
can I just say it's like the second time
she's like doing something that Kylie's
done and she's like
the second one to do it you know yeah
but I do think in differentiating her
price point and her offering yeah she's
separating herself more from Kylie Wears
Like kkw Beauty and Kylie Cosmetics the
same Factory like yeah same formulas
yeah so I don't know I just feel like
she doesn't need this I feel like she
doesn't need this like between being a
lawyer between skims between fragrances
between relaunching Beauty the new show
I feel like she really does not need to
do this yeah that's how I felt too but
the set at some point she's doing
interviews it looks like her bathroom so
if you want that Vibe like I like the
Kylie cosmetic the Kylie skin Vibe even
though I don't really use a lot of
Kylie's skin either I bought it and like
used it but never replenish but I leave
them in my bathroom because I like how
they look yeah they're cute vacuuming is
cute but like this aesthetic is cool but
it's not it doesn't matter yeah
so that's that on that we'll keep you
posted if either one of us tries it out
but I am very interested I would try it
for sure
give it a shot maybe we'll get PR not
after this episode this one is so
terrible these days oh it's gorgeous no
I'm in a rough place with my skin so
maybe it is time for me to switch it up
are you ready for our next story yeah
which really slipped under the radar but
Jada Pinkett Smith addressed
the Oscar slap on red table talk
remember that totally slipped through
the radar I didn't even read the story
yeah she said My Hope Is that Will Smith
and Chris Rock will reconcile Jada
Pinkett Smith is reflecting on the
relationship between will and Chris two
months after will struck the comedian in
the face at the 2022 Academy Awards at
the beginning of Wednesday's ride table
talk Jada said into the camera about
Oscar night my deepest hope is that
these two intelligent capable men have
an opportunity to heal talk this out and
reconcile with the state of the world
today we need them both and we all
actually need one another more than ever
I mean I agree with that sentiment but
not in this scenario like
um I'm just at a place with Will Smith
and Jada we're like I really don't want
to talk about them anymore like I'm
about to China them because even before
this I think we like stopped talking
them about them really quick because
even before the slap like they were just
doing too much you know like airing
their really personal Dirty Laundry
about their marriage and their family
and the entanglement and it was like a
lot for people and I think people were
already over them and then the slap
happened we were like we're done so
you're done I don't know like I think
they waited too long to respond and now
like I don't even know what they could
have said to make me think that like
what he did was even slightly okay
because I don't think it was okay so no
nothing they say could really make this
better and I think they probably know
that which is why this was like sneaky
under the radar statement yeah
I agree with that like My Mind Is Made
Up about all of this yeah like I'm I'm
not gonna change the way that I feel but
what's crazy is that for so long like
red table talk and Jada were the voice
of reason and you know you would go and
have these conversations and like if
Jada was on your side we're all on your
side and after the slap situation you
just look at them look at it differently
no and I don't think it's going to be
the go-to place anymore no and the show
was so good like conceptually like it
was so you bring it to the table it was
so simple like you know three
generations talking about it at the
table and then moving on from it and I
think that like what what it did for
their family was amazing because I think
it really made people respect them and
think they were really smart and I
watched many episodes obviously Jordan
Woods Olivia Jade
um and they just felt like they were
like really
um
like stable you know and then with the
entanglement everyone just I mean at
least me and I think a lot of the
sentiment was like eye rolling like keep
some things to yourself for sure but
even still with the entanglement it was
like tea worthy but it's still I was
still like okay the red table is where
you're gonna bring it dish it and move
on from it but after the slap again
Beyond The Pale yeah this is it's too
much so I'm just like I'm needing a
break from them you know and I'm just
waiting for I don't I don't want to make
my decision until I hear from Chris Rock
we still haven't heard from Chris Rock
right and that's who we're waiting to
hear from right not Jayden the person
who slapped right the Slappy Yes Papa
our fifth and final story some exciting
bad bad news Heidi Montag is pregnant
expecting her second baby with Spencer
Pratt she told us weekly on Wednesday I
couldn't be more excited I don't know
who I'm the most excited for myself or
Gunner or Spencer Gunner is their
four-year-old son this is really
exciting because if you watch the last
season of The Hills they were really
trying uh very much to get pregnant and
now it has happened and that's really
sweet for their little family yeah I
only watched the first season of the
hills and they were talking about it
then so I imagine it took them a while
to get pregnant so you just love to see
a happy the fruits of your labor happy
news yeah Mazel Tov to them Mazel Tov to
the Montag prep family and Mazel Tov to
us for launching our new peach that is
where we're headed out we are headed now
to our influencer event we're literally
like between going viral and then like
hosting an influencer event like
Moguls Mogul
um so check out Peach thank you guys so
much for listening to the morning shows
we're back tomorrow for our final
episode of the week thank you so much
for listening to the morning doesn't
Monday Morning Show we did the fastest
stories that you need to know everybody
Friday on YouTube so if you're watching
this on YouTube please feel free to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available podcast and
we're podcasting events on Spotify
iTunes Stitch or public radio I already
castbox all the places so everybody
listen podcast find us morning toast and
leave a five-star review about how
beautiful stunning and smart we are hope
you have an incredible day you guys and
we'll see you tomorrow bye bye